hey guys I'm Ryan right I am Jerry today
we're gonna watch reactors anthem a
music video by shape where we do that
wanted to mention this is a sponsored
video from New Era I mean if you guys
are not familiar with them let me ask
you this what do you think of my new cap
what do you think of my new you can we
will wait for Rick I'll wait for a
comment to come in it's cool I'm not
gonna wait yeah it's cool new era I'm
like right there see that sign the logo
right there comfortable it's extremely
comfortable like suctions the head and I
feel that I'm I'm gonna be visit a
special guest download the you know app
because I'm gonna be doing a special
event on you now on Sunday and where I'm
going it's gonna be cold so I'm gonna
need a little cap like this that's right
can I try not yeah you can just it looks
comfortable
make it fast it's like a hug it's like a
hug for your head yeah it's nice isn't
it it's like it's colorful it fits
snugly and I'm wearing the LA Lakers
because I am a huge Kobe Bryant fan and
Michael Jordan yeah he played for the
Lakers too no he didn't he played for
the Knicks you [ __ ] yeah of course but
the Lakers Rock and I like this so
there's a link of the description box if
you want to get cool caps like this and
you era really could like they're
they're actually really reputable and
really respected me I don't like the
Saints um if you need some gear for your
next sporting event and make these and
make these like Nick they also make
snapback caps if that's your thing
anyway yeah we're gonna check out this
music video che is actually a reactor
who I came across several months ago he
only had like a couple thousand subs but
I thought he was extremely entertaining
to watch his personality is before
thoughts and after thoughts I think I
think he's really funny too and he does
rap apparently so let's see what the rap
song is about maybe were talked about in
here
who
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
it's a very saturated market and I say
we need more
everyone knows I'm in high support of
that it forces you to grow again um I
want to see if the lyrics are here oh
alright alright let's briefly it's
quickly scan these this is good to us
that's really what we care about tapes
precaution with his next kid double are
on his chest highly respected right
right his objective react with as many
girls nipples are always forgetting
Jerry as real as can be Veronica never
want her to leave oh yeah I know
Veronica's never gonna leave
can someone sell Brandy's sweet sugar as
candy she's the prettiest girl in the
scene um yeah she's something right I
mean she's pretty she's really pretty
I wouldn't like ever think of her in
like a sexual way must can't tried many
times bunny girl matching Ellie cute
casual okay who is bunny girl she is
she's pretty cute you have to Google or
or go on the YouTube
I don't like searching for videos on
YouTube really yeah unless it's been
requested unless I know make viewership
off of checking out the video what's the
point yeah the point if it don't make
money it don't make sense that's not
true at all hey you know said that Jesus
Christ that was a cool rap man you know
like I rap too
and I want to do my own reactor song as
well because I notice there's other
reactors who are doing songs about the
reactor
world there's been Cooley I'm Dante now
they're che okay now it's time to show
you [ __ ] what's up [ __ ] what
I'm gonna dis all y'all people like
separate Tyrone I like Tyrone a lot I
like Shay - very cool I'm excluding you
guys I'm coming after all yeah oh boy I
don't know I don't know there's just so
many reactors now already I think I
might have found some inspiration to
write a rap song you know you're gonna
play out of beef track yeah it's gonna
be a beef track oh yeah track about why
reactions are the [ __ ] and why I'm the
best okay at least pop rap records yeah
yeah yeah yeah now that I said that I
just welcome to flooded comments of
people saying why I'm not the best oh it
doesn't matter really all that all that
matters is that you perceive yourself as
a bit you know what I have as number one
on my playlist boy that's on repeat all
the time of my guys look out fronting
keep a lookout for my rap song um I will
be releasing it because now it's time to
show that I too can be a badass rapper /
reactor as well I want to be part of
this community really bad anyway guys
listen if you're new to the channel you
can click this button right here to
subscribe to the real rejects Jerry has
two playlists on this channel don't
forget about it reasons - Jerry and dank
ass Stubbs don't forget about it I mean
if only if you want to remember and I do
want to give a shout out to Shay Shay is
one cool [ __ ] Jerry yeah
Boston beat we you know we you know we
gonna we gonna do a little shout-out to
Shay right now bus bus 9 + the beep
I go around here and I seat shake he
makes me happy every single day see his
reaction see his facial reactions go
around here give me facial expressions
he's a beautiful God Asian guys can't
deny that he's a Asian guy I love the
way he looks I love the way he shoots me
it looked
I love the hooks that he gives in his
videos you know he's got a good show
you know I'm home o4j yes--she I'm gay
to be with you anyway you want me to go
go in your butt hole go around here and
make you feel whole what don't you know
that'll also scrape off the old mole I
want to do something to make you feel
whole I hope this doesn't cause you a
big [ __ ] toll I want you to be some
body for me I want to make love to you
romantically I want to go around in his
story and say that we the two reactors
that hooked up over and over again I've
been you in your ass